- I have a bit of a
history with monorails.
Back in 2016, I visited the Wuppertal
suspended monorail in Germany,
and I said that monorails are
almost always a bad idea.
Monorail enthusiasts
sent me angry messages,
but I stand by that.
In 2020, I visited one of the last surviving
Roadmachines cargo monorails.
They were actually useful and practical,
but they were temporary constructions
designed for having cargo
hauled around work sites.
And they've been replaced by modern
heavy construction equipment.
Monorails are usually bad ideas,
because the track has to be either
elevated or in a trench,
and because switches at junctions
involve moving the whole track.
In almost every case, a monorail is
a worse and more expensive idea
than light rail, or a tram, or a bus.
But. While I was researching
a while ago,
I found a type of monorail
that is useful and practical
and better than any
alternative for its job.
And not only is it still in use,
new versions of it are being built.
So I reached out to the
company that makes them
and I asked them, "Can I
have a go on one, please?"
This is the Monorack.
- We build mainly ropeways.
That's our main business.
Everything with the rope.
Aerial tramways, chair lifts, ski lifts.
And Monorack is a Garaventa product
since nearly 45 years.
In 1978 I think, or '79.
Some two years after the petrol Monorack,
they start with electrical Monoracks.
They installed mainly in the Alp area.
Germany, Switzerland, a
lot of Monoracks in Italy,
but also Canada, Sweden, Asia.
All over the world we have more
or less about 800 Monoracks.
The petrol Monoracks are mainly
installed in the agriculture area.
The electrical Monorack usually is quiet,
but here the customer made his own box.
That's the reason why it's
still a little bit loud!
- The invention that
makes this thing so useful
is down on the track.
This is a rack railway,
so the track has grooves
and the cogs onboard
the train lock into it.
That means it can climb
very steep hills like this
and take tight corners
with no risk of slipping.
Having just one lightweight rail
means it doesn't take up much room.
It can go around tight corners
and it's easy to install.
Being elevated, means it
can go over rough terrain
and if there's rain or mud below,
it doesn't matter.
I genuinely can't think
of a better solution
for regularly, safely,
moving things up and down
steep, rough terrain like this.
- Every Monorack is based on a brake,
and on a engine chassis.
And what's between the two chassis
is up to the customer,
we can choose different models,
different chairs,
whatever the customer needs or wants.
You can see the charging rails.
If the customer wants two or three,
he can choose two or
three charging points.
Normally we have only one,
in one of the end stations.
- I know this sounds like an advert,
I promise it isn't.
I just got actually properly enthusiastic
at being proved wrong.
There are useful monorails in the world.
And this? This is one of them.